this quest to bring impact and purpose
and I think this is what drives me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside of Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
welcome to 20 minute leaders today I'm
with Larissa Amir managing director of
Merck's Healthcare r d Center in Israel
she's the member of Merck Global
Healthcare Discovery technology
leadership team leading Global projects
and teams across geographies and
cultures she is also part of a women in
leadership program mentoring leaders in
healthcare
Theresa is an executive leader with
broad experience in the pharmaceutical
industry from large-scale companies
through small medium businesses to
startups she has extended experience in
process development analytics
manufacturing and Technology transfer in
the frame of pharmaceutical regulation
Theresa is involved in major business
decisions of startups companies growth
strategy product portfolio due diligence
and Technology evaluation for potential
strategic collaborations with companies
or investors
welcome a darisa Amir managing director
of work r b Center in Israel thank you
so much for being here how are you
I'm great thank you for having me really
exciting to be with you
hi Mary I'm excited to dive into your
world for these uh 20 short but awesome
images of the world of healthcare the
world of work the world of research and
development from your side before we
dive into to Merck research and
development what does it even mean to be
the managing director of it and what
your personal passions are within your
current line of work tell me a little
bit about your own your own Journey we
we just shared with the audience a
little bit about who you are and your
past experiences but connect the dots
for me as to sort of what brought you to
the person you are today
can we measure
I am actually I've started my
professional career and as a lab
scientist
at the Young Israeli biotech company
which was a joint venture with the
Weitzman Institute
with a Clear Vision to develop
recombinant proteins for therapeuticus
and at the time I can share that this
was completely new domain in
pharmaceutical development using novel
recombinant DNA technology for
biological drug development
um I guess you know you know that
traditionally
drugs drug development was was of
chemical molecule entities and not
biological large molecule and so so so
obviously it felt super pioneering and
and also it was a quiet enlightening
period of time
where I actually learned what was
required to develop a manufacture
analyze a new molecule and taking
through the entire regulatory path
and eventually register it as a new
medicine for patient you know it's super
exciting and eventually this drug became
a blockbuster drug today selling
annually in more than one billionaire
Euro worldwide so I think it's quite an
achievement for a small biotech company
and
and in Israel and and for me obviously
it enabled the you know a very steep
learning curve and and since then I I've
I have had a very Dynamic career yeah
I'm joining a startup company in the
field of glycobiology where we were
pioneering with glycoanalysis using
reluctant on a chip
and then later I took a consultancy role
supporting a small emerging biotech
companies in the field of regulatory and
compliance and in product registration
and again here one of the companies
actually reached the market and widely
used when their hepatitis B vaccine
and now
um I'm over a decade with Merc
which is a multinational company as you
know and at work I had I had done local
Regional and and Global position
basically leading projects and team of
of increasing gay scale and scope across
borders and incompetence
and and I can share that that my last
role actually
required the relocation to Germany
um Charlie blue
um alone without my family wow
where I spent there nearly three years
so so basically I've taken the global
product quality position a leading
multinational Group which was
responsible for the product quality of
healthcare portfolio basically late
stage and early stage molecular
development as well as life cycle
management of commercial product so
really the entire Healthcare portfolio
and here again I can proudly share that
during this period of time Merck has
launched a last product
um
and and my team is heavily supported
with with that launch which is a cancer
treatment for non-so cell lung cancer
for patient with the with a specific
genetic mutation
and in six months ago I'm back to Israel
becoming the managing director of the
healthcare Research Center and I'm proud
and privileged to lead a group of
talented and creative scientists
which are today part of the global r d
organization and and are involved in
several strategic
Global discoveries
phenomenally obviously I have to say
that your your dedication and your
scientific nature and your your love for
the science and for the the research and
The Innovation here really you know it
shines through and and I'm curious to
dive deep a little bit onto that so
USA as a researcher as a lab scientist
as an innovator in this field
let's dive in a little bit what that
means to you what is that process entail
for you as a researcher and what really
does it align with your own set of
values or or characteristics
I think I think um
looking at my I mean I think I can think
of several uh you know
things that that you know brought me to
to who I am today
so obviously one of them you know myself
my my personality
my characteristic my background
I think ever since I remember myself
I've always wanted to do something
meaningful
but but you may say who doesn't I mean I
always
wanted to make an impact and and always
had this starvation to to do more and
more and and I always ask myself what's
you know what's next
so with this constant wish to
to go beyond and above and and and
I and and I think that this is something
with my inner personality and so
this has been enabled obviously in in in
in in this development in this biotic
World which always there are new things
and and and and there is purpose and and
there is an impact because we are
touching you know human lives of course
how do you choose what problems to deal
with how do you choose what
you know as a scientist you can decide
to dive into many different fields how
do you make how do you decide what is
the most relevant field for you right
now to be dedicating either as a lab
scientist back then when you just
started or even more so today as a as an
r d managing director that you have to
now sort of shine the light on on what's
the relevant Direction here
so I I think that that you know it's
it's
a Glo as I am as part of the global
organization basically you are
um you you follow the the global
strategy it's it's not that you are
um
do what and you don't do what you want
you you are in line with the global
strategy and and one thing which is a
strongly I advocate is that we need it's
a small you know it's a small site in
Israel part of the global r d we need to
be globally
um integrated not locally independent
and so obviously we do bring a lot of um
ideas and Innovation to the table and
this goes for them you know through the
big company governance and and we choose
but this whole needs to be within the
strategy of Merck which is today in
immunology and oncology mainly
so so so these are the like the driving
force of course we are complementing it
with with an external Innovation and we
are constantly looking at the um you
know the the Israeli biotech is a
the Israeli ecosystem let's say is super
vibrant and rich in ideas and and and we
at tomorrow are for open for for
collaborating with with the academic
groups
um with the uh with entrepreneurs with
clinical and research sites so we are in
all kind of different you know models so
and I think that this is also enriching
the the the the the r d internally
incredible and so if you're looking now
at you as a managing director of the r d
what is your vision for for Merck in
Israel what is your vision for you as a
managing director here of this r d
Center where is it at today where do you
hope to for to become and what needs to
happen for it to be that way
so I
I think the I think the challenge ahead
of us and I think it's it's well known
that the biotech process aiming to reach
it the patient is is very lengthy and is
very costly process it takes on an
average I don't know 12 to 15 years
in approximately I don't know 2.5
billion euros to bring a product to the
patient to the market
and so I think that all Pharma companies
aspire to enable faster and precise
development of of innovative medicine
with less failure at the end of the road
and I think to do so we will need
as a whole you know all the all the all
the Pharma companies to capitalize on
early stage breakthrough innovation
and of disruptive Technologies mainly
coming from this intersection of biology
and Technology by basically combining
bio and Tech capabilities and bringing I
don't know computational and prediction
tools the artificial intelligence to
machine learning robotics 3D printing
organometry human tissue samples and
many many more Technologies
to make this what we call translational
process from molecule Discovery to human
medicine more efficient more precise and
more sustainable by maybe reducing use
of animal for pretty clinical testing
and all this all these efforts are
already started to be done and and
hopefully ending up with more success in
the end of of the road
and I think that this would be possible
through collaboration as I said with
academic groups with research centers
with the clinical centers where they own
the clinical data
and hospital as well as with the
governmental programs entrepreneurs with
with the you know state-of-the-art
Technologies and would end with also a
you know competitive Industries and and
in this field of of AI we are now
collaborating with with the with four
different
multinationals so we have astrozenica
Teva
um
and
Merck and the third one
Pfizer and Pfizer yeah together with
Amazon web services so so this is a
basically a collaboration to see how we
can reduce or make it more efficient
effective efficient the whole
drug Discovery using AI Technologies
basically
you mentioned the early stage
breakthrough Innovation what did you
mean by that what what is that you know
unfold that that term for me so so as I
as I mentioned there is um a lot is
going on on on the um
under
let's say on the intersection there is
there is a lot there is going on with
for example organ on a chip I mean to
replace animal use
this all these 3D printing and using
using basically live cells is is is a
very early stage it's a breakthrough
technology I mean 3D printing of organs
it's using its for to test
um medicine it's it's not something
which is you know obvious
so this type of things that we need to
like look for
and is that common for every r d group
in the world to be looking at these not
obvious things in sort of a merg global
idea or is this something that you're
particularly excited to to bring out
from the Israel ecosystem
well well the Israeli ecosystem is the
of course supporting heavily in this
external innovation formwork
yeah obviously it's that there's a lot
of innovation and the device and from
Europe
um
but Israel with its uh insects and as I
mentioned uh it all started uh 15 years
ago when when when Merck has is
published here a r d Center and I think
that Mark is the only one in Israel that
has an r d Center
um and so this paid off because because
today
um
because today we have I mean with this
with this initiative
Merit has brought
two Blockbuster from the Israeli
Discovery so so basically they it paid
off at the end
being very very cool
has research in your context changed
much over the last
you know
years as you've as you've seen it emerge
you've been in work I believe
2009 or so as have you observed sort of
Shifting mentalities in the way this
research is done or the way these
products are built you know as we're
progressing technologically are we also
advancing conceptually from the the ways
in which we're approaching these problem
spaces or the ways that we're thinking
through how to generate early stage
breakthroughs
yeah I mean I mean technology has
evolved so much and you cannot you know
keep the the old-fashioned way although
the regulator
I think that this this this
pharmaceutical industry is heavily
regulated by
um as you know FDA emba so I think that
the the advancement also shouldn't be at
the regulatory path yeah because because
we need to comply with what is required
and and and so there is um there is a
you know conflict of of I don't know if
it's a conflict but you need to to to to
to to close this gap between the brakes
for Innovation and you need to uh
um let's say convince the The Regulators
that this is the right path so if that
is happening and if the regulator
approves the drug with the new
state-of-the-art technology then it
becomes you know like a standard of of
of of use
so it's it's not easy nothing is easy as
you know it's not that Tech
environment it's much more traditional
it's much more heavier it takes longer
and because we are dealing with with
patient life so
right that makes a lot of sense so you
know one of one of the things that I
really love about this show and you know
one of the reasons I do it is to
understand why people do what they do so
I'm poising this question on to you now
Larissa why why do you do what why have
you been doing what you've been doing
all these years
what excites you about it what what
motivates you about it
well I think I don't know I mean I
as I said I mean ever since I remember
myself I I I I wanted to do something
meaningful and and I think that that
people
um normally would like to do something
meaningful in in life and maybe maybe
it's related also to my
um
you know to my background I I mentioned
before I mean as a child as a daughter
for for for a Russian immigrant
who made Aliyah to Israel in the late
17s I think I was five years old at the
time and without knowing knowing the
language or the culture you know
struggling to stand on my old feet
um in a new country
I think I I could not rely on my parents
you know for help with with school
assignments or will
question about I don't know this new
totally different culture so so
basically I had to deal with everything
by myself and I I tried to Excel and I
think that
um this is also my what my parents has
has uh have expected me to do no matter
what and I think that this this
you know
notion or my ambition to to raise the
bar and and challenging myself but but
also my my surrounding I always
challenge you know the my peers and
colleagues and I think that at Merck I I
found this the enabling environment
which is aligned with with my curiosity
and my ambition my my passion to
challenge barrier and for for you know
for this quest to to bring impact and
purpose and I think this is what drives
me basically
Marissa thank you so much for your time
your energy and the thoughtfulness best
of luck with a running words r d Center
in Israel it's a very you know it's a
it's very a lot of Pride for the Israeli
ecosystem and I'm excited to see the
breakthroughs and The Innovation coming
out of it so really thank you for your
time and your energy and uh best of luck
thank you very much
thank you
[Music]